Metra boyfriend who you talked about in
your act and a very sweet guy I know
that I'm an important figure in your
life and I approve yes it's my comedy
father yeah and does it it sounds like
it bothers you that he had an easier
upbringing than you
oh I resent him every day of my life but
he lets me do jokes about him on TV so
like what do you can't be mad and he's
really cute like what are you gonna do
yeah but uh ya know I've had to work
through that for sure I think it's
probably similar when you have kids like
your kids probably easier than you had
yes they do growing up yeah yeah they do
yes they do actually so I have that
mentality but with my partner where I'm
like when I in my day we had to walk 40
miles in the snow without shoes but it's
like my dad didn't hug me as much like
you know that kind of do you do you say
throughout your your dating life even
though you say it hasn't been that long
or that extensive have you received know
what I mean
are we inferring yeah that was that
would be me I guess all right will you
hold it up no did you get did you
receive a lot of relationship advice
from family and stuff when you were
because that might be a little it sounds
like family maybe a little more
repressed which is something I can
identify with or religious you might not
get good relationship advice well yeah I
mean when you grow up religious they're
like the safest sex is no sex which is
like saying the safest travel is books
you know it's true but you know but I do
as you're right I haven't like had a I
started dating kind of late like when I
was an adult and I was allowed to so I
have I do ask people a lot for
relationship advice especially when I'm
on the road doing shows and I get a lot
of interesting answers I had one I had
one couple tell me recently take
separate vacations it is like yeah when
you get a moment to relax and enjoy
yourself you don't let your spouse ruin
that for you
that's I had someone else some I've
never heard I have to say ever heard
take separate vacant maybe where people
say try and have separate closets or if
you can have separate sinks separate
vacations yeah I had someone tell me
love is a choice
you just keep choosing each other you
know love was a choice which all I heard
was I'm not happy but I'm no quitter
[Laughter]
[Applause]